India has not really had a sort of
severe impact of the financial crisis
the impact has been somewhat muted
because of prudent financial management
as well as some basic structural factors
which have insulated it from the global
financial crisis and I could recite
specific reasons for that but some of
them include the fact that our economy
has been primarily domestic focus of the
dependence on West for demand as well as
for capital has also been somewhat
limited secondly our financial system
has always pursued the policy of more
prudent management a banks are well
capitalized we've not had exposure to
toxic assets and these are some of the
factors that have contributed to
insulating a somewhat from global
conditions
would compare with European countries i
think is still much much better off our
financial institutions not even one of
them is broke even in the beginning of
the subprime crisis the only impact was
the fact that there was actually
increased liquidity into india as a
result of fed rate cuts in the u.s. so
there is power regulatory response was
really to try and sterilize the extra
liquidity that was coming in as far as
the second major milestone event in the
financial crisis the lehman bankruptcy
even that didn't have much of an impact
because they're very little counterparty
risk which indian banks had to to lehman
or events which flew out of that so
we've had a muted impact that being said
the global conditions have had some
impact in as much as capital flows have
been have been reduced and have been
more subdued our capital markets have
stock markets have fallen quite
significantly since the since the peak
they are reviving in more recent weeks
but they further there at one point of
time come down